[Music]
Godzilla the king of the monsters a near
Unstoppable force of nature well nearly
Unstoppable he has been killed and
defeated in a few occasions over the
years and a few times by weapons created
by Humanity so here in this video we
will showcase five deadly weapons that
have put down the big G or at least
stopped him in his tracks and no we
won't be including the Mecha Godzillas
here let's get to it number one the
oxygen Destroyer well the very first
Godzilla was killed by this weapon in
1954 then the second time it was used
was used to a less effect in the
monsterverse movie Godzilla king of the
monsters the oxygen Destroyer was
actually the invention of a Dr dauk
serizawa so having devoted his studies
to the element oxygen serizawa
accidentally stumbled upon a volatile
and deadly chemical reaction filled with
the micro oxygen its payload the larger
capsule the weapon operates by pushing
its ends inward causing the rods to
release the micro oxygen while the exact
composition of the micro oxygen is
unspecified it is hinted that these
miniaturized oxygen atoms possess
greater chemical energy the device is a
Wy apparatus with a metal capsule
containing a glass Central chamber
holding a second capsule with rods this
volatile substance reacts with water
isolating and liquefying oxygen MO ules
organisms including the Kaiju exposed to
the chemical first suffocate then
disintegrate the extent of Destruction
depends on the released chemical amount
ranging from skeletal erosion to
complete
Annihilation number two the EMP probes
these weapons were featured in Godzilla
planet of the monsters that anime movie
they were employed to defeat the smaller
Godzilla filers and then were later
replaced by the EMP harpoons to combat
the much larger Godzilla Earth but
failed to do so in the second case so
Godzilla Filas like his father possesses
an em Shield an electromagnetic Shield
generated by an organ in his dorsal
plates they discovered that disabling
The Shield by targeting and destroying
this organ when The Shield is
temporarily inactive they could render
him powerless until the organ
regenerates thus he was defeated by the
United Earth forces who took this
advantage of this opening this inactive
opening and then planted the EMP probes
into his body during the shield power
down time causing electromagnetic energy
to accumulate and overload until he
finally exploded number three the
anti-nuclear energy bacteria so the
anti-nuclear energy bacteria is a
genetically engineered super weapon
utilized in the 1989 Godzilla versus
bolante the jsdf began a project to
genetically engineer a strain of
bacteria capable of feeding on and
breaking down nuclear materials however
the bacteria required a certain genetic
code to allow for the production of an
enzyme that breaks down down nuclear
materials into an edible form the only
known source for this was in Godzilla's
own cells since his primary food source
was nuclear energy and therefore comes
the okui foundation that had the only
viable Godzilla cells in storage so they
develop it and during the battle between
bolante and Godzilla they fed Rockets
filled with the bioweapon against the
Gman at first it didn't seem to have any
effect but when they fired the MAA
Cannon the temperature was increased and
the bacteria was uh activated and
multiply like crazy rendering Godzilla
too weak to fight and almost died only
to be saved by the cold waves of the
ocean lowering down his body temperature
so this weapon managed to subdue
Godzilla almost killing him and then
sending him to hibernate for 3 years
underwater number four the blood
coagulant this liquid was used as a last
ditch effort and as a chemical weapon to
subdue Shin Godzilla the blood coagulin
mentioned in the movie is a substance
designed to freeze Godzilla's blood and
IM mobilize him Shin Godzilla was prone
to overheating after evolving as well as
firing his Atomic breath attacks
therefore sending him to a temporary
state of dcy to cool down so here the
chemical referred to as the blood
coagulating drug was meant to keep Shin
Godzilla in that state of domancy
indefinitely so the protagonist and his
team were employed and worked to
formulate this drug as a part of
operation yashiori and after overcoming
initial difficulties in creating the
formula the later succeeded and
initiated the plan during the final
battle with Godzilla the first attempt
failed due to Godzilla's spare power
which he uses to Counterattack with his
Atomic breath however the second attempt
succeeded with 80% of the coagulant
injected into Godzilla as a result
Godzilla initially rises again but then
suddenly freezes becoming immobile and
rendering him domen well you know until
an eventual sequel is released number
five the orthogonal diagonal lier
featured in the anime series Godzilla
Singler point it serves as a super
weapon designed to manipulate the base
archetype which is a group of
transdimensional molecules notably the
primary form known as the red dust these
molecules exist transdimensional
extending to other dimensions forming
the basis of the body and structure of
Godzilla and other kaijus in the series
The orthogonal diagonalize represents
the 13th and ultimate form of the
archetype achievable only through the
superdimensional calculator upon
activation within a matrix of red dust
it initiates a reaction causing the
rapid consolidation of red dust
particles into massive blue crystals the
unfortunate K you caught in this process
are swiftly immobilized or killed as
they become impaled by the growing
Crystal formations coming mainly from
themselves this weapon was activated by
Jet Jaguar in a final battle against
Godzilla Ultima killing both itself and
the Big G in the process so those are
the five Super weapons that defeated
Godzilla and if you like this video then
watch this otherwise as well and if
you're more interested in other movie
Monsters then check out our Channel we
might just have things that you haven't
seen before like subscribe and we'll see
you in the next video take care
fam